Alright, enough about bears. Now, I'm going to get back to the
question that we started this unit with and ended the previous
unit with, which is where those mysterious magic methods came from
when we didn't define them. Recall that we defined our restaurant
class like this and for now, we don't need any other
definitions. Because we saw before we even had any methods that
we got some behaviors, we got initialization and we got printing
using the magical --str-- method. So, the question is, what's going on?
So, the choices are something magical and,
and mysterious, and I'll tell you not to
select this one. Restaurant is inheriting this
--str-- method from object and it's being called,
when we do the print, with a
restaurant instance and restaurant inherits the --str-- method
from object, and it's being called with
an object instance. Check all the true answers.